[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode
of what's up Prof hi Martin how are you
Walter well Martin uh the closer
we come to the end the happier I
become well I share that enthus iasm well
let's open with a word of prayer our heavenly
father thank you once again for giving us the
opportunity to do a discussion like this we
need you to Enlighten our minds and help us to
discern what it is that you want us to discern
and also to spread the word to the people so
help us and protect us with your angels and we
ask this in Jesus name amen amen now Martin once
again we always start with saying that we are
not politicized yes we are observers right very
important and we are trying to fit world events
and tendencies into the prophetic picture and we
know that the world will be forced to worship the
Beast and His Image yeah and because it is an
issue of worship there must be a shift from the
secular world to the religious world yes and so
there must be ideological Transitions and as we
discussed or as we have often discussed there are
uh these tendencies in humanity like going from
the Age of Reason to an age where spirituality can
again play a part because the Age of Reason hasn't
satisfied the requirements of the Soul that's true
so our backdrop is quite informative I think we
can see the movement in in uh do what thou wil
is the whole of the law to a more uh biblical
based ideology yeah and the Man in the center
there is looking at the divide and the shift he
has a a white cuff and a pink cuff and I think
people can make them their own decisions as to
regard the dichotomy of his thinking yeah that's
true the movement towards the American flag part
will definitely then be more legislative and
mixed not in the biblical sense yes so let's
have a look at what you have put together here
I think uh this could be interesting we start
off with the solar storm and this is news 24
brought rarely seen Aurora to South Africa
but may have caused internet cable outage so this
weekend extreme solar storm brought a rare Aurora
sighting to South Africa for the first time
since 1989 but also may have been the reason
for an internet outage that hit South Africa
and several East African countries on Sunday
what did we struggle to upload the last uh episode
it was quite a nightmare and I'm sure the people
saw that it was late and it it was just out of it
our networks cell phone networks internet nothing
worked yeah and we struggled for hours and hours
and hours to try and upload and people probably
thought what happened here but it was beyond our
control we blame it on this on the solar storm
we blame it now haven't they been talking in the
world economic forum for a long time about such
events which will take place whether naturally
or unnaturally they call it Cyber attack yes
it could be a military activity it could be
a hostile Nation trying to take down networks
Martin we are not going to take sides here but
is it possible that these are not necessarily
natural phenomena but practice runs well I'm
we are labeled as conspiracy theorists well
then be one let's theorize a little bit it's just
interesting that there's always they well we'll
see now in a on these uh articles the one says
it's this the one says it's this the one says it
it's a natural thing the other says it's manmade
so well well Satan is studying the Laboratories of
nature so he maybe his agents is hard at work
yes let's have a look here's an article from
my Broadband warning about solar storm that could
cause blackouts a severe solar storm this weekend
threatens to trigger blackouts disrupt navigation
and of course NASA has some interesting photos
that they take and put out there for people to
peruse uh that had lots of interesting photos
in the past that turned out to be Photoshop
activities so let's not be too hard on them
they're probably beautiful photographs with
their most special telescopes this is the first
time since January 2005 the US space weather
prediction center has issued a G4 geomagnetic
storm watch the second highest on a fstep scale
has multiple waves of solar energy Bear Down on
the planet so the last time Earth was hit by
a G5 storm the worst on the scale was October
2003 causing power outages in Sweden damaging
Transformers in South Africa Sweden and South
Africa are about as far apart as they can come
right yeah the North and the South well I don't
think well this is dong and Chek but I don't think
South Africa has um recovered from that one yet
because we still got blackouts going on regularly
since then especially with our our electricity
system and grid but at least we've got an election
coming so we haven't had any power out eaches for
quite quite some time it's amazing how just before
an election everything comes right for a while and
then Telcom which is the telecommunication Giant
in this area says Network restored after massive
internet outage well they certainly disrupted
our last upload so Telcom is investigating the
cause of a massive service Interruption affecting
the company's internet and phone call services on
Monday so Martin what happened to all the cell
phone companies like vodom and NTM and Telcom
and all of them so there were widespread
Internet outages on almost every internet
service provider platform when four cables snapped
on the west coast at the same time seemingly due
to seismic activity now it's interesting how the
solar flare produced seismic activity yeah that's
hop can produce seismic activity mhm and a lot
of other things as well as including Aurora you
know these conspiracy theorists they drive you
crazy because they never believe anything that
is officially put out there in the world they
always speculate that human fingers are somehow
in the pie I think we fortunately we're not of
that ilk so Martin I've come to the point where
I don't believe anything anymore I don't believe
anything the only thing that I believe is what the
is the Bible is that the only thing you believe
the rest is all based on lies and deception it's I
even to try and prove it's like uh scientific
theories that are seen as facts these days
Evolution for example I cannot believe that I was
an evolutionist I don't want to get into that but
I cannot believe that I believed such nonsense but
you know what's the problem I saw a video and I
put the link in um the description for this video
when I was going through these things that tell
you what this solar flare and all of this will be
and it's like in the evolution Theory there's so
much scientific jargon and stuff that they throw
at you that you think wow this must be true this
must be true there will be a time of trouble such
as never was that's an axiom isn't it now a time
of trouble means that there will be outages
and disharmony and people will be discomforted
on every level and Satan knows the agenda so
he must he must almost frighten people into
a particular direction and that might require an
ideological shift yeah it now remember the French
Revolution was fired by the Jesuits yeah Vol was
a Jesuit yeah so it was fired by the Jesuits why
because Catholicism has lost its power yeah they
want to gain it back so they bring in an Age of
Reason which ends in turmoil and then say we
have to go back to the good old Middle Ages
where the church was in control it's where they're
going exactly it's a very clever thing it was an
interlude and they have time oh they they can can
do it over a century or two or two another article
from unilad scientists are creating an artificial
Aurora in the sky to conduct experiments so Martin
if they're admitting that they're doing that
what was the cause now a natural phenomena or a
experimental phenomenon so just for the people
that like to label conspiracy theorists to us
well then you have to say that to the people
that actually do it as well okay so with a huge
advancement in science in recent years experts
have been able to discover some pretty wonderful
things now it's interesting that Tesla in his days
managed to produce these things so it it's not all
based on modern science but maybe on hidden
science yeah yes one of these things is being
able to create an artificial Aurora in the sky to
conduct experiments and let's blame it on the Sun
the high frequency radio wave transmitter known as
The High Frequency active auroral research program
harp facility in Alaska will create the phenomenon
in the sky for 4 days from Saturday 11th November
in order to carry out experiments on the
ionosphere yeah and we must remember this wasn't
now this was a while back so this was a while back
and it just shows that they're quite capable of
doing it m mhm so you don't know whether it was
a natural phenomena or an artificial phenomena
I like well let me say I liked what you said
earlier maybe it was a test run for something
and then they just blame or shift the cause of
it to somewhere else yes so nobody is at fault
so what about this harop research program uh well
this was interesting because the dates of the AR
Aura of the northern and southern part where the
northern and southern lights could be seen was the
same dates that the research campaign for harp was
running all right so they're admitting that the
HARP program was running but they saying it was a
solar flare and other ones say that it was damaged
to the cables by seismic activity so the solar
flare produced the seismic activity or H produced
the seismic activity well let's leave that to the
conspiracy theorists to sort out so what what is
this research all about here's an article from
the University of alas Alaska Fairbanks scientists
at harp use HF radiotransmitters to heat small
regions of the ionosphere and observe the effects
for additional space research using groundbased
observations or experiments on sounding Rockets it
can take an extremely long time days weeks years
to get the desired natural overhead conditions
satellites can amass much larger databases but it
is difficult to coordinate the satellites with a
desired phenomena well isn't it interesting that
whenever there's a major seismic activity or a
major earthquake or a tunami that you have these
Aurora appearances in the Sky correlation is not
necessarily causation yes you're absolutely
right now it's interesting that people notice
these things and of course if you bounce these
these uh these waves of the ionosphere you can
actually Focus where they will penetrate and
they can create earthquakes this is this is
basic knowledge now Tesla did that he actually
called but of course they will never use it for
anything negative that is conspiracy so with a
facility like harp it is possible to perform an
experiment at will to create plasma structures
and irregularities use the ionosphere like an
antenna to excite low frequency waves create
weak luminous Aurora like glows and a variety
of other experiments like earthquakes armies
etc etc yeah all right from experiments with
harp and with the natural phenomena let's move in
the direction of where these fear mongering things
can actually lead to exactly and we're talking
about an ideological transision aren the thing
is all of these tools are used to event get to
what their plan is and the ideological shift has
to come about because like you mentioned light
at the beginning we have to go to a religious
thing yes it has to because that's what prophecy
says will happen so here is one of the interesting
magazines America it's of course the Jesuit
review the Jesuits are not my favorite people
as most people will probably have noticed Pope
Francis accepts invitation to the 2024 G7 Summit
the first pope ever to attend now why do we throw
something like this in it's to show that no matter
where you stand ideologically whether you're
talking about an lgbtq Flag Ceremony within Roman
Catholic circles or whether you're talking about a
G7 Summit it somehow seems as if the papacy cannot
be left out of the equation never he's never
excluded he's on every side he's always there
MH so whether you move from the left to the right
or from the right to the left the Pope's going
to be there that's the missing link that people
don't get together so in a surprise announcement
on April 26 the Italian Prime Minister and it's
interesting she's the one that saw to a a shift
to the right back to family and religion and all
of these things uh Maloney said that Pope Francis
had accepted her invitation to participate in the
G7 Summit in Italy's apulia region on June 13 to
15 his presence brings Prestige to our nation and
to the entire group of seven so uh the whole world
wandered after the Beast I wonder whether she
consult the other six don't think it was necessary
I think they're all on board they probably all
Rejoice yeah now this gives Prestige to the entire
meeting in addition to Pope Francis Argentina's
president he also does a flip-flop every now and
then doesn't he will be one of the guests who
are not members of the G7 isn't it fascinating
that they invite as a guest one who is taking
also the ultra conservative shift to the right
that's what you have to open your eyes that's why
we have to be observers because a lot of people
will be very glad to follow Maloney and Malay
because they want to get rid of the globalists
on all these enemies of humanity but then they
you you must open your eyes and see where they
gather and whose hand they're holding and aren't
they super pro Trump as well you see so Francis
met him in the Vatican on February the 12th where
he did a great flipflop from attacking the pope
to embracing him right yeah he will attend the G7
working session especially that part dedicated to
artificial intelligence she described AI as one
of the great challenges facing Humanity today now
what when they release something like AI to the
world uh it is a it is a known strategy in the
world that if you have a technology you must first
have it under the belt and control it before you
release it to the world so AI has probably been
used in the military for a long long time already
and now they're pretending that it has just popped
its head out of nowhere yeah and now they want to
introduce rules and govern it but in the meantime
we don't know what's happening behind the scenes
and how much control they actually do have right
and I read the other day in the news that the new
Jets fighter jets that they are producing should
scare The Living Daylights out of everyone and
they are totally AI controlled so they already
have the technology in in place and now they're
saying well let's see how dangerous this can be
it's like introducing the atomic bomb right that's
it now M if you want to create an ideological
shift in thinking uh with what generation would
you start with the old fogies or with the energy
of the youth didn't rabam do the same yeah rabam
also said let's listen to the youth and discard
the old fogies and the ideological systems of
the world communism or Nazism or whatever they
were they employed the youth they had the youth
brigades Hitler had the Hitler Youth and they were
the driving force because they were manipulatable
yeah yeah that's true so let's have a look how
they can use these things and uh how they did
it in the past and how they can possibly do it
today inspired by Soviet Union dictators Vladimir
linen and Joseph Stalin China's communist leader
maong borrowed from the Playbook of the Russian
Revolution to fight anti-communist forces lenen
organized a military branch of his Communist Party
known as the Red Army following suit ma branded
his army the red guards however Ma's soldiers were
not enlisted from his military his red guards were
made up of high school and University students so
he used young people to start culture Revolution
to top down statues burning old buildings and
demonize all religions going after all dissident
voices and to turn all the Chinese against
each other family look at the mouse culture
Revolution to say how many similarities are there
communism will yesterday I asked chat GPT
are there any similarities between today's
woke Revolution and chairman Ma's cultural
revolution of the 1960s and it wrote back
how long do you now we hear a lot of talk today
about right-wingers left-wingers extremists and
moderates the political Spectrum concept if it
has any meaning at all is a measurement scale
showing all the variations in government now the
extremists at at the zero end would be those who
Advocate no government at all the anarchists the
extremists at the other end would be those who
Advocate total government and who are they well
the Communists of course but also the Nazis the
fascists no matter what they may call themselves
if they Advocate the debate is not between
conservatives and liberals it goes back in history
long before those words were ever invented the
opposing points of view properly are identified
ifed as individualism the individualist believes
that the rights of the individual must not be
obliterated by the desires of the collective
or the group The collectivist on the other hand
believes that the group is more important than the
single person within it and that the individual
must be sacrificed if necessary for the greater
good of the greater number the individualist
believe that every man has a personal and direct
responsibility to provide first for himself next
for his his family and then for those outside his
family who may be in need the collectivist on
the other hand declares that the individual is
not personally responsible for charity for raising
his own children providing for his aging parents
or even providing for himself for that matter this
is a group function of the state of government
itself modern individualism versus collectivism
where does the pope stand on that issue oh on the
collectivism side he despises individualism now
if you have to make a choice between the biblical
world view and a collective world view then
you have to make an individual choice is that
not so that's true you cannot make a collective
choice no I cannot hide behind a group religion
no I have to have a personal decision we
will stand as individuals in the judgment
yes you will not hide behind the cloak of anybody
so if the papacy is against individualism when we
have an ideological shift will he again be against
individualism for certain so collectivism must
rule yeah in other words there must be Collective
laws that's it and those laws must be obeyed for
the sake of the greater good yeah the common good
as we always common good which is collectivism and
if you refuse to bow down no and there were
only three Hebrew youths who refus to bow
down you could just end up in the fiery furnace
that's it is that where we're heading we saw it
a precursor and we are definitely heading for that
all right now when you see all these riots in the
world today and you look at the ideologies that
are involved and no matter what what the slogan
is the SL can be anything it can be lgbtq it
can be abortion it can be anti-Semitism it can
be black lives matter whatever any any of these
ideologies any one of them then they are a move
towards collectivism now what if you can rile up
an entire religious group an entire generation of
religionists to find solace in their collectivism
and their ideology wouldn't that be equally
dangerous definitely I you remember we showed that
person on Christian nationalism where he said this
is the rules that will be implemented you can live
here but you'll have to adhere to it you'll have
to adhere to it all right so if you if you shift
from let's say a statue bashing window destroying
building burning car burning violence to the other
collectivism have you actually solved the problem
or actually made it worse without knowing of
course you've made it worse even though it looks
better it looks better because that looks good it
you want you don't want Anarchy you don't want the
cars burning but the other portion is just as bad
all right even if not worse it's like we mentioned
when Nebuchadnezzar accepted Daniel's God he
wanted to make a law that everybody should obey
exactly that was as bad as as as it was before now
here you have this book The Catcher in the Ry and
uh it was also in M Gibson's movie on conspiracies
and of course it is uh virtually compulsive
reading in Jesuit circles and also one of the
most banned books in the US yes so it propagates
violence and rebellion in order to achieve
an an objective is is this what the world
is experiencing it's definitely and most teachers
want their pupils to read this book all right now
if you are an observer and you see the burning
and you see the violence uh is it possible that
you could jump onto the other bandwagon just for
the sake of peace and Sanity for sure for sure we
and we see that so is it very important that you
have a very very distinct guideline like the word
of God and we have to know what it requires of
us because some people will get on the bandwagon
without even knowing what the bible really
teaches okay so if you want to Channel people
in a in a direction and to create a ideological
transition because ideological transitions don't
come by accident no it is a planned very organized
operation right they're implanted in the mind and
you can use whatever your tools are and you
actually create the tools yeah you create
front organizations so that you're never the
guilty party the Jesuits are very good at that
they have all these front organizations and front
people when they are actually the instigators
behind the scenes so here's an article from India
Today Jewish billionaire George Soros linked to
Pro Palestine protests in the US now this man is
often depr portrayed in the media as the great
villain mhm put sitting behind the funding of most
of these revolts or anything Mass migration he's
funding the people paying them to come across the
border now if the governments are fighting these
things and they know that this is the culprit why
is the man not incarcerated and put away why is
he allowed to do whatever he thinks is wonderful
whether it is favorable or not it can only be if
um they want him to do it they want to do turn
a blind eye towards it why do they want him to
do it because they want the outcome or up yes and
what do they what do they use youth most of the
times yes let's use the youth let's rile them up
promise them a drug or two yeah yeah or even pay
them you know yes I mean the Jesuits did that in
the hippie movement they went around in the in the
Volkswagen combies full of flowers handing out LSD
carrying on and instigating all these things so
what does he do Jos sarus the Jewish left leaning
philanthropist and Association funded by him are
reportedly fueling the Countrywide Pro Palestinian
protests on American campuses Martin we should
look way past the protests we Bast I agree with
you and ask ourselves what is the ideology behind
it mhm is it uh to create a rallying call for
the religious world to Rally together and to bind
together and say you know these are the people of
the book we really have to stand with them this is
exactly what's going on there's method in their
Madness they want a certain outcome and it is
definitely to push towards this religious because
like youve always Jud culture and say this is
enough and there's enough Kingdom theology whether
you're dispensationalist or not uh involved there
to strive for it true and you can get rid of a
lot of uh law just to bring in unity in religion
yes and and they're using ideologies like the
Millennium the Roman Catholics are actually
amillennialists yeah they're just saying when the
church rules that will be the great time that's
what they're waiting for so it has been uh funded
by networks of nonprofit organizations which were
in turn funded by Soros a billionaire who is known
as the man who D stabilized the bank of England
he's got so many so-called crimes under his belt
but he's allowed to do just what he wants and
his counterpart is musk yeah on the conservative
side they're playing a a game thesis anti-thesis
synthesis okay so what are they basically
trained to do whether they receive money
for it or not is immaterial they are trained to
rise up to Revolution that's what they have to do
and A revolution is there to change the mind
of someone to change the mindset either for
the revolution or against the revolution so they
can even want this Revolution and that's what we
believe they're doing to get people to say we've
had enough of this we've had enough we want the
other side of the story we've had enough so we
have a Dutch anti-islam party says it's broke
at the provisional Coalition deal for a hard right
government now this is also very fascinating to me
because this Wilders wers is is the way probably
pronounce it uh he is this anti-islam you know
we're a Christian Nation we want Christian norms
and when you look at Dawkins we had him in a
previous program didn't he say I'm an atheist but
I want uh Christian cultural norm I'm a cultural
Christians he says because I want to live in a
Christian and I'm sick and tired of these other
religions telling us what to do I want to go back
to Christian standards and Norm who will stand
out as the Numero Uno Chief Indian when it comes
to that well obviously the pope obviously that's
why he's being invited to the G7 exactly exactly
I think he's just as happy to see him there than
Malone is absolutely now who are the Nations
that are actually moving towards the right in
this ideological shift Finland CAA Hardline right
parties are part of European governing coalitions
and hard right to populist Prime Ministers are
leading Hungary Slovakia and Italy Sweden yes
this is all very fascinating and uh there are
all kinds of conspiracy theories with people
trying to assassinate some of these leaders
and some of those leaders were anti what uh
some of the World Health Organization people
were saying so we we won't discuss this now is
there a possibility we might discuss it in the
future yeah it's very interesting the SL vacan
prime minister that was attempted to assassinate
him because and like you mentioned the world uh
Health Organization pandemic treaty that he didn't
want anything to do he didn't want to take part in
that but that's conspiracy so is there a shift
definitely now they're mentioning countries like
Hungary Slovakia Etc is the same shift taking
place in France yes very much so very much so
right and uh is it did it take place in Sweden
yes so is Germany on the cards yeah all right
so this is a very interesting time we're living
in people are saying we're sick and tired of what
the Age of Reason has done to us we want to get
back to something else so this Dutch fire brand
wers joins new government as Europe's liberal
Elites put on notice so the EU elections are just
a few weeks away and the liberal Elites are in
absolute panic because the sharp jump to the right
is inevitable across Europe he claimed that this
shift is being led by the youth mhm there we go
right so whether it's for the the Anarchy side or
whether it is for the conservative side the youth
is going to be involved we saw these left-wing
authoritarians destroy their lives during Co
consistently suppress their national pride invite
the third world into Europe while they can't find
a job little Alan enough money for a house is that
Generation X yes definitely comes from the 60s so
let's reject that which was in the past let's
move to something else we can either go with the
Anarchy and tear everything down or we can turn
back to Christian nationalism and stable laws like
Dawan says let identify as cultural Christians
at least and that's where the danger is lying yes
an article from Newsweek Republicans voting for
Bill that could make the Bible illegal outrageous
Maga so the Maga conservatives voiced outrage at
Congressional Republicans voting for anti-Semitism
awareness act over concerns it would make the
Bible illegal is Faith coming into The Fray the
whole time it's not separated anymore anywhere
I mean the pope is going to the G7 yes so some
conservatives are taking issue with the bill over
the definition of anti-semitism including claim
of Jews Killing Jesus or blood liel they have
made a Coalition in their mind with the Jewish
system dispensationalism runs through their mind
they don't realize that dispensationalism comes
from the Jesuits it's another tool it's a tool
it's a lie it's based on a false interpretation
of who the Israel of God is your house has been
left to you desolate desolate you have to be in
Christ to be Abraham's SE and HS according to the
promise so they're worried that they would make
the Bible illegal while the definition in the bill
does classify the idea that Jewish people were
involved in in Jesus as anti-semitic it does not
make the Bible illegal people of the book let's
go back to the Bible is there an ideological
shift of definitely but I think these people
have to go and uh go back a little bit because the
pope if I'm not mistaken has cleared the Jews of
any guilt yes he exonerated them from from their
guilt they were most elated it was the Romans that
killed him but who handed him over to the Romans
did Je now Martin if you can portray society as it
is today in its most ridiculous light could that
be an incentive to create an ideological sift to
something that is more rational even for people
that are not religious I'm sure even for people
that are not religious right like the dorines
of the world for sure now we we can't live with
this this is totally ridiculous so we're going to
show something about furries explain to them what
furries are furries are people that identify as
animals oh and they find them in the schools right
yes especially in schools I mean we've referen
to where they put litter boxes cat litter boxes
in schools for those that identify as cats well
now there's been some uising about children that
cannot handle this anymore I can't handle it
anymore now that's really ridiculous you know
M when with my rebellious I would use those boxes
all the time just to make the teachers clean them
up but let's let's see how how this is panning
out you know about the pro Hamas protest at Ivy
League schools but how about a furry protest a new
trend has emerged where some children believe they
are animals known as furries they purchase furry
animal ears paws tails and even collars online and
wear them to school this may seem harmless but the
truth is these students are causing disruptions in
their school studies recently some students at
Mount neibo Middle School in pacon Utah walked
out of class stating they had had enough the
furries were making it difficult for them to
walk down the school hallways without being
molested they either bite us they scratch us
they they run all and counts on people
actually is not something that's been occurring
in fact a lot of the information that's been put
out there is completely Incorrect and inaccurate
however the students say it is happening and some
parents encourage their kids to act like animals
because they believe it's healthy for them to
role play and use their imagination folks this is
beyond imagination this is crazy and we wonder why
test scores have declined and this country faces
a shortage of about 55,000 full-time teachers
it's time for schools at allow this to happen
to crack down against the furries humans are
not animals but what do we expect to happen when
adults tell children to be whatever gender they
feel like being on a given day and now whatever
animal they want to be see the progression
here let's remember that God made us in His
image male and female he made us for his purposes
we are a reflection of a Divine Creator not the
animals that he gave us the authority to rule over
it's time to get back to Reading Writing and Ari
itic not eating Kibbles and using litter
boxes sorry they may be CED and sometimes
fun for costume parties but fures have no place
in American classrooms the M what is this is this
a it's just just another tool that they using to
get ideological shift that's it this has become
from the sublime to the ridiculous let's get back
to some Norms some norms and sensibilities right
so let's get an ideological shift now uh they can
buy these things online so are the mega companies
playing their role oh for sure are they just
in it to make a buck or is it to move a trend
along in order to get another Trend I think it's
both I think they are helping to move the trend
along because the top of the top is really knows
what's going on but the rest is just uh yeah we're
doing it for profit so the hegelian dialectic and
the industry and the media they're all involved
definitely who controls them who said this we
not saying this the Bible predicted it correct
so modern would it be useful if in this climate
of of ridiculousness we suddenly see a massive
movement and ideological shift towards religion
and people taking their stand and particularly
uh media people and stars taking a stand for
religious issues it it's bound to happen because
like you mentioned not everybody wants to be part
of the ridiculous they're going to say we we have
to get back some Norms okay and they will choose
a religion and then everybody will be uh surprised
and maybe follow suit true all right so here's the
National Catholic Reporter I'm sure they related
because Candace Owen converts to Catholicism so
the Fri brand conservative commentator Candice
Owen has announced her conversion to Catholicism
a long expected move for the controversial 34
year-old black ideologue so she announced the
news on social media on Monday afternoon April
22nd describing it as a decision to go home
now you know this go home sounds like Vatican
2 m the separated children please come home is
Catholicism playing a major role here oh you see
Catholicism is also mastered brainwashing yes and
propaganda so a lot of these people probably like
you mentioned or we've mentioned numerous times
it's not the people but it's the the system system
so it looks like the wonderful system to go to
if you don't know any better imagine how how
easy it is to brainwash children for example
to think that they're cats or whatever there
is of course so much more that went into this
decision and that I plan to share in the future
but for now praise be to God for his gentle but
Relentless guiding of my heart towards truth long
identified as reformed Evangelical Protestant so
M she was a long identified reformed Evangelical
Protestant but she's now going home to truth and
that truth denies the atonement that truth has
changed the Commandments of God and that TR truth
has replaced Calvary with a mass yeah and the and
the intercessor for the Saints and Mary yeah
now Martin this is horrendous but the world is
saying nothing because they've been brainwashed
into saying nothing exactly they don't know any
better they don't know any better but we have
to do some about truth again we have to do some
evangelism shall we hear what she has to say oh
sure there is a reason why Carl Marx who you could
argue one of the most successful philosophers ever
he is the most successful philosopher he's in in
terms of having his ideas implemented in society
why he wrote so excitedly against the concept of
family not just the Communist Manifesto but all
of his other works too it would it it became a
tenant of the government if the government wishes
to grow and supersede in individuals and supersede
families we need to make the nuclear family look
bad because they knew that what it would produce
if you don't aspire to family if you don't aspire
to Children is a fundamentally selfish individual
and an individual that is willing to get into
this almost intimate relationship with the
government they don't believe in God they're
atheists they believe in more governance as a
solution to everything everything is temporal
everything is instantaneous and in the moment
and so it's interesting that as Russell Brand
moves away from his socialist and communist
radical leaning past and moves toward family
he is now also talking about faith it is our
job to die so that as Christ died on the cross
he might be reborn in us it's not just me that
is experiencing A Spiritual Awakening across the
world there appears to be a return to religion
and obviously if you were asking me for my
personal recommendation I could only use my
personal experience as the basis for a personal
recommendation but across the world this seems to
me like a time where a set of values not
derived from the materialist culture are
becoming increasingly relevant when you look at
that ghoulish Gala that was the White House Press
correspondence dinner it's pretty obvious that
we are a rudderless society damned and doomed
and beautiful I know a lot of people are sort
of cynical about the increasing interest in
Christianity and the return to God but to me
it's obvious as meaning deteriorates in the
modern world as our value systems and institutions
crumble all of us become increasingly aware that
there is this eerily familiar Awakening and
beckoning figure that we've all known all of
our Lives within us and around us and for me
it's very exciting Now ladies and gentlemen
the mainstream media who absolutely adored him
when he was deep in his addictions hates him
really think about that and I will tell you I am
a big believer that Hollywood was created by the
CIA I believe that I've firmly believe that you
can say that's a conspiracy theory when I think
about all the societal ills when I think about
how they artificially place people at the top
of Hollywood who are preaching toxic principles
routinely anti- family principles now definitively
satanic principles it just should make you pause
and wonder why is that why is that why do they
reject someone like brand when he's coming up and
recognizing that family and faith is turning him
into a good person and yet adore individuals as
they're deep in their addictions I'm just going
to leave you guys with that thought all right so
how important is the family structure to her very
important now the heart of Catholicism exactly
isn't that the family it's 100% and isn't it
uh free time for the family yes and isn't Sunday
worship part of that yes the whole Sunday movement
is geared towards family wasn't that part of rum
novarum already mhm yeah that was to dictate the
whole of the economic world's uh activities or
what about lat see that's it but you see how
clever Satan is and so the ends justify the means
what is Hollywood other than Jesuit theater so it
was to create a scenario that would be despised
in the end so that you can get to where you really
want to get the pendulum to swing is it swinging
they are succeeding in what they've put in plan
years ago already now the plan is so brilliant
that there must be a super strategist behind
it and that strategist is Satan yeah he inspires
people to do certain things and she admits that
Satan is behind it but she doesn't realize that he
might be behind the movement that is taking place
now as well that's the most dangerous part you
know it it is so scary to think because I know of
a lot of people that's caught up in this you get
caught up in it because it seems this is the right
thing to be happening this is right it's wonderful
that she's converted converted but now you have to
give her the total truth because yeah have to get
out of this Sy out of the system so Mar what is
interesting it doesn't matter who the media Mogul
is or the mega star or what role he plays here
you have Bear Grills help baptized Russell Brand
in the river temps and how did this happen now M
uh tell us a little bit about Bear Grills what
Bear Grills May is famous for he does all these
um survival stunts that where he goes into they
drop him in a remote place and then he shows some
survival skills that's not very palatable he he
eats anything that creeps and crawls and shoves it
into his mouth and everybody is horrified but he
is a he is a well-known figure and people on the
millions watch his Antics right and I'm if I'm not
mistaken last year he took Russell r on a on an
Excursion and they talked a lot about faith they
talked about faith so now they are helping each
other to be baptized uh it's sending a message
Nick Hilton looks at how Bear Grills and Russell
Brand who are both linked to the same Evangelical
immersion program came to end up in the thems
together it's sending a message that's it and
even though it can be a really good heartfelt
conversion it's unfortunately in this stage still
part of their plan it's still part of the plan
and it's leading towards a particular ideological
shift I think if Satan was sitting back he doesn't
matter if there's some collateral damage in his
um eyes like say some of these truly convert it
doesn't matter to him because he's as long as he
gets the overall picture yeah now it in in here in
the Catholic Herald it says that Russell Brand was
baptized while making a bleak Catholic references
so Russell Brand is more on the Evangelical side
and here he is making Catholic references and of
course he was previously a Buddhist so who
was previously a Buddhist announced that he
had taken up praying the rosary later
he teamed up with the Catholic prayer
app hallow and revealed he had been watching
videos of popular YouTube personality us Catholic
priest father Mike schmidtz it's also known that
bran has attended an alpha course which Advocates
the inquiring on fundamentals of Christian
belief and is run by the church of England
and has attended a Catholic church so is this a
very ecumenical approach yeah now praying The Rose
taking part in the alpha course we've discussed
all of these in great detail in previous lectures
and we've shown that they are programs which
are not exactly as the Bible would say things
should be run right unfortunately it's part of
the brainwashing so here we see an ideological
transition yeah people are suddenly becoming
religious and the Catholic Church is always in
the fry he's always in in there all right another
Point that's quite interesting Martin is that
uh Candace Owen has lined aligned herself with
the Conservative Catholics and uh like Cardinal
Schneider for example Bishop Schneider now this
is very interesting because they're quite vocal
against Pope Francis MH so they leaning towards
the conservative side but if you remember we've
mentioned Malay zavier Malay of Argentina he was
also very against the pope on National Television
yes and where did that end up yeah ended up
with him embracing and gesticulating it's not
just a celebrity here or there right this seems
to be a real ideological transition yeah so let's
have a look at some of the the people involved
and uh what impact they have why do you think
it is that it seems like more big bigger name
folks are becoming Christian to some somee like
Candace Owens Ander your bride yeah Ian her Neil
Ferguson Russell Brown Joe Rogan Douglas Joe what
you doing about Joe Rogan yeah well Joe's Joe's
already he's he's got a foot in the camp he's a
lot less um disparaging of Christianity that he
once was which we all really appreciate thank you
Joe Joe figured it out Joe figured it out yeah
Dawkins called himself a cultural Christian like
two weeks ago well why well how about because he's
terrified of the Islamic fundamentalists how about
that so afraid that he won't speak against them in
public right well there's something to think about
Oh you mean the Christians had something right
as time rolls on people are going to understand
the need to have some sort of divine structure
to things some sort of belief in the sanctity
of love and of Truth and a lot of that comes from
religion a lot of people's moral compass and the
guidelines that they've used to follow to live
a just and righteous life has come from religion
and unfortunately a lot of very intelligent people
they dismiss all the positive aspects of religion
because they think that the stories are mere
superstitious fairy tales that you know they they
have no place in this modern world and you know
we're inherently good and your ethics are based
on your own moral compass and we all have one and
that's not necessarily true we need to do we need
Jesus I think for real like if he came back now
it' be great like Jesus if you're thinking about
coming back right now now's a good time pretty
soon yeah now's good time well there's a lot
of people that think that that might be coming
well it might be mark of the beast if there is
the Christianity part and and Jesus wants to come
back and save everything it'd be good right around
now yeah like don't wait till the election I agree
with the principles that Jesus advocated um and
that the you know there are some some there's
great wisdom in what in in the teach teachings
of of Jesus uh and I agree with those teachings
um and things like T the other cheek are are very
important because as opposed to an eye for an
ey um an eye for an eye leads everyone blind so
forgiveness you know is important and um treating
people as you would wish to be treated love thy
neighbor as thyself very important I call myself a
cultural Christian I'm not a Believer but there's
a distinction between being a believing Christian
and being a cultural CHR Christian and so I sort
of feel at home in the Christian ethos I feel that
we are a Christian country in that sense that I
like to live in a culturally Christian country
although I do not believe a single word of the
Christian faith so Martin is there an ideological
transition taking place I think it's a very very
clear it it two years ago you didn't see any of
this no so it's been very rapid very rapid so the
last events will be rapid ones rapid ones now when
you see this shift should you rejoice or should
you become very careful and introspective very
careful introspective and really find out what
does god require from you how important is it that
the great controversy gets out there to people
well I believe that it's probably except for the
Bible one of the most important books that must
be spread around the world now absolutely because
we are right there we are seeing the foundations
being laid for what the scripture says is going
to happen and people need to be aware of it and we
are not here to denigrate these people we're not
here to say that their experiences are not genuine
but we do have an obligation to warn them as
to where it's heading yes America needs Jesus
America doesn't need a to turn over a new Leaf
America needs a new life and and new life is
only given on God's terms as the sheer grace of
God it's got that's how it's got to be and so
we what we need is preachers Christian preachers
who will stop being ashamed of the name of Jesus
and preach the gospel and preach the gospel as
though it's supposed to spread out uh into the
streets after the service so too many churches
are Jesus boxes where where you you go in you
have your meeting with the with Jesus in your
box and then you go out and live pretty much
like everybody else that's right you try to
keep your nose a little bit cleaner than the
average guy but you you still fit right in
but I believe he does so I believe that if
our nation were destroyed for our arrogance
and conceit by Fireballs from Heaven you know
if if God were to do that uh it would be not
unjust it would be a just judgment we we have
been arrogant in the extreme and I would say the
central arrogance there's there's fruits of this
arrogance Downstream the 60 million children
who were aborted the the various things that
we do um the going around the world preaching at
people how to get their life together threatening
them killing them when we don't know how to
live our lives all of that that's the fruit
of the central sin the central sin is secularism
the SEC the secularism is that we can we can live
decent orderly lives without Christ we don't
need God in order we don't need God in order
to live um uh placidly the way we did in the
Eisenhower years with black and white sitcoms
where Father Knows Best and you know we can we
can do that and I'd say yeah okay how's it going
we the grand secular experiment is now at a
point where they don't know what a girl is
that's because secularism is not a biologist right
they they can't tell you what a girl is they can't
tell you what a human being is and if you if
they can't tell you what a human being is how
can they tell you what human rights are well they
they can't and they and more more than that they
don't want to because because they want to move
us around as though we are just uh pieces on the
board that they you know to to to gratify their
whims and their theories so secularism is the
idea that we can establish agnosticism or atheism
as the official faith of the country and govern
ourselves decently without reference to God that
is radically false we can't do it has it ever been
achieved anywhere in history that you're aware
of no well M that just hit the nail on the head
the enemy the sin is secular ISM yeah now isn't
that King of the South exactly pushing against
the king of the north but isn't he sitting at the
same table and planning this with the King of the
North and that's what we've been saying the whole
time so the Jesuits create the one atmosphere in
order to bring about the other atmosphere it's
called hegelian dialectic right and it's working
very good it's working obviously practiced it in
in communism practiced it in narcism they're very
good at it and they are the enemies of God and man
yeah and fortunately they will not much longer be
tolerated on this earth when when Jesus returns
when that stone strikes the statue the entire
statue the entire image of Daniel 2 is ground to
powder that means the entire political system that
has been erected on this Earth is ground to powder
and then it is blown away not a vestage of it will
remain and if you do not make the right decision
now then you will be blown away with that dust
that's it never to exist again and very serious
if you just say where are we in the Stream of that
statue yes it's right through up until the point
you always say in the toenails yes it's in the
toenails and the violence that we see in the world
and uh the confrontation this is a typical north
south ideological confrontation and the King of
the North is coming against the secularism with
everything that he has we're seeing it right
here for sure and he's going to overrun it and
he's going to try and plant his tent in God's
environment and a lot of people are going to
say this is good because it looks good if you're
not grounded in what that real it only looks good
relative to what went before exactly now some
of these celebrities that we're mentioning like
Beck for example they are not unaware of the book
that we spoke about the great controversy so that
information is out there but my problem is Martin
that the noise that is created might just drown
that voice of reason that is there amongst them
there's so much noise yeah yeah that if we do not
focus a bright Beam on that information it will
be lost that's it so even if you have and that's
a very good point even if you have the great
controversy on your shelf doesn't help you nothing
even if you've read it and you put it back on the
Shelf still it doesn't help you so a whimper won't
cut it it has to be allowed cry yeah is the great
controversy by EG white it is about the battle
between good and evil we are seeing that play out
more and more in the world around us every day
this book next to the Bible to me is probably the
greatest book I've ever read you know why because
it tells about the past and the present and the
future when we turn away from God from his true
principles of the Bible we all get ourselves in
trouble and I believe this nation today is in
great trouble we need to get back to biblical
principles that are practical in our everyday
lives this great controversy will change people's
lives even the great Paul Harvey when he was alive
told me personally this is one of the greatest
books that he had ever read it's amazing book and
you know Glenn was just telling me this is the
one that people sent to him more than anything
I get books sent to me all the time people
send me books that book is sent to me more
than any other book I I I bet I have I bet I have
received in the Last 5 Years 500 copies of that
book easy so Martin the information is there and
this is 10 years old the video yes all right so
the information is there yeah but the bright beam
is not focused on it because people are running
with a noise yes what is our task our task is to
pinpoint them to the truth truth ah okay so this
is the entire focus of the ministry am mean to
bring this truth to the world so this discussion
has transcended the Age of Reason yes you can see
that the Age of Reason even Dawkin okay sure but
it's moving into another Direction yes wasn't his
evolutionary theory supposedly based on reason
yeah when there was no reason to base it on in
the first place but listen how these these media
people are actually speaking let's just hear what
they have to say so you bring up you bring up god
so let's go to a even bigger picture when I
said when do it start I I think you know when
you a third of the Angels were lost um and uh
you know Satan is cast out that whole argument
was about individual choice you are going to
choose you are going to yes you're going to
suffer and you're going to you know whatever but
you will have freedom of choice Satan said no no
no you don't want them all to suffer you don't
want all of that what kind of person are you I
thought you were a good guy now you're making
everybody suffer and you're saying some of us
are going to be lost I'll tell them what to do
I think what we're experiencing now is the same
battle that is found in the falling of a third of
the angels and it's the same I think it's the same
argument as well how do you get a third of the
Angels who are seeing God all the time praising
him standing there they know who he is how do you
get them to turn on him you have to make him into
a monster through compassion you have to say hey
he wants some of you lost he's not going to save
everybody he wants you to suffer I'm telling
you there's a way to not suffer do you think
of that theory you're absolutely correct and and
one of the things that you see and this has been
going on for hundreds of years is this movement
to try to make that exact argument right God is
oppressive God's got all these rules for your life
you know how how mean of him to say that you shall
not and you you must do this uh you know why not
have total freedom and you see actually a lot of
self-proclaimed satanists make these arguments
do what thou Wilt shall be the whole of the law
right we don't need to obey those silly moral
codes uh you know who who does God think he is
to impose those things on us and and for a long
time those kind of Base instincts especially in
the Western World were held in check because the
rest of society said no wait these are important
these are these are good things but now we see
that breaking down after a period of multiple
generations of constant attack uh indoctrination
of multiple generations of children and so we're
now moving into a new phase of the battle but
I agree with you this is all the same struggle
between good and evil that's been going on from
the dawn of humanity and um it's it's maybe a
new phase in that battle but ultimately the core
of the battle is still the same and what stands
out in that discussion is these moral laws uh
we don't need them that's what Society thought
but look where where it's gotten us right in the
past when those Norms were adhered to society was
relatively orderly yeah now we have all of this
chaos is this an invitation to bring those moral
laws back definitely but there's a but there's a
kicker there's a catch there's a catch cuz there's
always a catch when Satan is involved which
moral law will they bring back the Catholic
one the Catholic version does that have the fourth
Commandment in it yes no doesn't it has a third
commandment because they chucked the second one
out of course yes and they've changed the day
yeah what about the second commandment that's gone
gone then split 10th commandment into two yes so
Martin here's an interesting point they're going
to run with the Catholic version of course and the
problem is the mark of the beast yes they will not
grasp it completely because it's linked to the for
commandment so if I could make an appeal to
Glenn Beck if you have 500 copies of the great
controversy please just read one yeah just one
so by the decree enforcing the institution of the
papacy in violation of the law of God our nation
will disconnect herself fully from righteousness
When protestantism shall stretch her hand across
the gulf to grasp the hand of the Roman power
when she shall reach over the abbis to clasp the
hands of spiritualism and when under the influence
of this three-fold Union our country shall
repudiate every principle of its Constitution
as a Protestant and Republican government and
shall make provision for the propagation of
papal falsehoods and Illusions then we may know
that the time has come for The Marvelous working
of Satan and that the end is near so is the end
near Martin I believe so I believe so definitely
as the approach of the Roman armies was assigned
to the Disciples of the impending destruction of
Jerusalem so may this apostasy be assigned to us
that the limit of God's forbearance is reached
that the measure of our nation's iniquity is full
and that the angel of Mercy is about to take a
flight never to return the people of God will
then be plunged into those scenes of Affliction
and distress which prophets have described as the
time of Jacob's trouble now the sad part is that
these people sincerely want to put this record
straight but they've been lied to and they fall
into a trap whose job is to warn against the Trap
the church The Remnant church now if the remnant
Church doesn't do that AR they failing in their
commission from God of course now what if some
people within the ranks say that if you actually
do that you're a terrorist yeah no then I'm then
let there be even War that's it unfortunately
that is not what we are for this church is not
an ecumenical Gathering Church no the judge of
all the Earth is soon to arise and vindicate his
insulted author it the mark of Deliverance will
be set upon the men who keep God's Commandments
who rever his law and who refuse the mark of
the beast or his image God has revealed what
is to take place in the last days that his people
may be prepared to stand against the Tempest of
opposition and wroth those who have been warned
of the events before them are not to sit calm
expectation of the coming storm comforting
themselves that the Lord will shelter his
faithful ones in the day of trouble we are to be
as men waiting for the Lord not in idle expectancy
but in Earnest work with unwavering faith it is no
time now to allow our minds to be engrossed with
things of minor importance while men are sleeping
Satan is actively arranging matters so that the
Lord's people may not have mercy or Justice
the Sunday movement is now making its way in
darkness this is exactly what we are seeing and
we we show it you can see this and we cannot be
quiet the leaders are concealing the true issue
and many unite in the movement do not themselves
see whether the undercurrent is tending they don't
see it no unfortunately like I said there's a lot
of people that are probably honest and yes
but you have to wake up it's professions are
mild and apparently Christian but when it shall
speak it will reveal the spirit of the Dragon
it is our duty to do all in our power to avert
the threatened danger we should Endeavor to
disarm Prejudice by placing ourselves in
a proper light before the people we should
bring before them the real question at issue
thus interposing the most effectual protest
against measures to restrict religion Liberty of
conscience we should search the scriptures and
be able to give the reason for our faith says
the prophet the wicked shall do wickedly and
none of the wicked shall understand but the wise
shall understand well Martin the Bible says that
the wise will turn many towards righteousness so
let's preach righteousness amen and righteousness
means right doing yeah and righteous doing
means being in Conformity with the law of God
and not with the law of man amen let's pray
Heavenly Father the world is experiencing an
ideological transision and precisely what the
Bible predicted is happening and yet the world
is fast asleep not knowing about the Trap that
has been set for them and there are a few that
understand the issue help them to speak with a
loud voice is my prayer in jesus' name amen amen
[Music]